This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We've all been there. You park your car in a giant lot, only to come back a few hours later, and have no idea where you parked. You wander around your arms laden with shopping bags, cursing. TV shows like Seinfeld,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们都经历过这种事。你把车停在一个巨大的停车场里，几个小时后回来，却根本想不起车停在哪儿了。你手里挂满了购物袋，四处游荡，嘴里还骂骂咧咧。像《宋飞正传》这样的电视剧，
milk these situations for laughs. How is this car, Brahma? We need a system! Oh, milk the situations for laughs. When things like this happen in real life, you probably don't laugh. Or take bigger things, you slip on the ice and you break a wrist. Someone leaves the stove on and your house catches on fire. Or the world suddenly and inexplicably is gripped by a major pandemic. Cases now topping 15 million here in the US, 1.3 million of them in just the past seven days. Jobs are lost, lives are lost. And as hard as it is to fathom the record number of COVID deaths, public health officials
把这种情境演绎得笑料百出。这辆车怎么样，布拉玛？我们需要一个系统！噢，把这些情境当作笑料。当现实生活中发生这种事时，你大概笑不出来。或者想想更严重的事，你在冰上滑倒摔断了手腕。有人忘了关炉子，结果房子着火了。再或者，世界突然莫名其妙地陷入了一场大瘟疫。在美国，确诊病例现在已突破1500万，其中仅过去七天就新增了130万。工作丢了，生命消逝了。尽管人们很难接受创纪录的新冠死亡人数，但公共卫生官员
are warning tonight that it will likely get worse before the situation improves. Life is filled with tragedies and hardship. For thousands of years, philosophers have come up with strategies to help us cope with setbacks. This week on Hidden Brain, an ancient philosophy appointment and misfortune. William Irvin is a philosopher at Wright State University. He has spent your studying how we respond to setbacks and how we might use ideas from philosophy and psychology to respond differently. Bill Irvin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, it's a pleasure to be here. I want to start with a couple of small examples of the kind of irritants we all experience.
今晚发出警告，在情况好转之前，形势可能会进一步恶化。生活中充满了悲剧和苦难。几千年来，哲学家们想出了各种策略来帮助我们应对挫折。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨一门应对逆境和不幸的古代哲学。威廉·欧文是莱特州立大学的一名哲学家。他花了一年时间研究我们如何应对挫折，以及我们如何利用哲学和心理学中的观点做出不同的反应。比尔·欧文，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。哦，很高兴来到这里。我想从我们所有人都会经历的几种小型烦恼开始。
You were recently taking a nap and you got woken up by a call from a telemarketer. What happened next? I was enjoying a mid-afternoon nap in the phone ring and I answered and it was just the robot and then I pressed the button that's necessary to get to an actual real person. When I got to that person, my sleep deprived brain, you know, I had that kind of fog. And I launched into a verbal attack. I rather surprised myself. I don't remember the details,
你最近正在小睡，结果被一个电话推销员吵醒了。接下来发生了什么？我当时正在享受午后的打盹，电话响了，我接了，里面只是个机器人，然后我按了联系真实人工客服所需的按键。当我接通人工时，我睡眠不足的大脑，你知道的，当时脑子里还一片模糊。然后我便开始了一番言语攻击。我自己都挺惊讶的。我不记得具体细节了，
but I do remember the phrase, you lying snake being among them. And it's like a part of me emerged from some back corner of my mind and simply took control, took control. And I was along for the ride, watching what happened. Yeah. So some years ago, you and your wife were on a vacation to Morocco. You were camping in the Sahara and you had scheduled a camel ride across the desert the next day. It's a once in a lifetime experience, once in a lifetime moment.
但我确实记得其中有一句是“你这个撒谎的阴险小人”。这就好比我内心某个角落里的一部分突然冒出来，直接掌控了局面，接管了一切。而我只是个旁观者，看着事情发生。是的。所以几年前，你和妻子去摩洛哥度假。你们在撒哈拉沙漠露营，并计划第二天骑骆驼穿过沙漠。这是一次千载难逢的经历，千载难逢的时刻。
But as you lay in your tent, your mind was filled with intrusive and unpleasant thoughts. What were those thoughts built? Yeah, no, it was supposed to be kind of this wonderful dreamlike adventure. And this particular trip featured a night in a tent. And it was a nice tent, you know, don't think pup tent pup tent think tent with an internal shower if you can imagine such a thing oh wow and two camel rides one at sunset and one at sunrise so I was very much looking forward to it they served us dinner there in the tent and then we headed off for bed I was about to drift off. I was tired. We had done a bunch of traveling that day. And just as I was about to fall asleep, an incident arose. I don't need to go
但当你躺在帐篷里时，你的脑海里却充满了挥之不去的不愉快想法。比尔，那些都是什么想法？是的，不，这本该是一场美妙如梦幻般的冒险。而这次旅行的特色之一就是在帐篷里过夜。那是个不错的帐篷，你知道的，别以为是那种小帐篷，想象一下里面带有独立淋浴间的帐篷，如果你能想象得出那种情景的话。噢，哇！还有两次骑骆驼的体验，一次在日落时分，一次在日出时分。所以我非常期待。他们在帐篷里给我们端上了晚餐，然后我们就去睡觉了。我正准备迷迷糊糊地睡过去。我很累。那天我们经历了一连串的旅程。就在我快要睡着的时候，一个事件浮现出来。我不必详述
into the details of the incident, but involving someone I knew, and it was an unpleasant incident. And I found myself getting angry. And you know, I could feel my blood pressure rising, that kind of anger. And I thought, well, this is really stupid because I have sun rise camel ride tomorrow. So I need to get some sleep. So I rolled over and the voice indeed went away until just as I was about to drift off to sleep, it came
那个事件的细节，但它涉及到我认识的一个人，而且是一件不愉快的事。我发现自己开始生气了。你知道的，我能感觉到自己的血压在升高，就是那种愤怒。我想，这真是太蠢了，因为我明天还要骑骆驼看日出。所以我得睡会儿觉。于是我翻了个身，那个声音确实消失了，直到我快要睡着时，它又
back. It just is this reminder. And that's kind of how it went through the night. And then I experienced what I call metta anger. It's a whole nother level of anger about getting angry about something as stupid as what I was getting angry about. So, you know, I kind of transcended normal anger. I feel that the stories you are telling are so universal. We all have these experiences. We stew over things, lose our temper, lose sleep over things. I mean, I feel I do this all the time.
回来了。它就像是一种提醒。事情就这样折腾了一整夜。然后我体验到了我所说的“元愤怒”。这是关于为自己生这种蠢气而感到愤怒的更高层级的愤怒。所以，你知道的，我有点超越了普通的愤怒。我觉得你讲的这些故事太具有普适性了。我们都有过这些经历。我们会为事情纠结、发脾气、气得失眠。我的意思是，我觉得我一直在这样做。
And when it happens, I tell myself, sometimes this is, you know, this is happening at three o'clock in the morning, this is so pointless. You're not going to feel rested in the morning. All this fretting is not going to solve anything. You have a wonderful analogy to how these thoughts operate in our minds. Tell me the analogy of the annoying roommate. Yeah so imagine that you're trapped in an apartment with this roommate and the problem was he was a very annoying human being. He would basically hang out in the back bedroom playing
当这种情况发生时，我告诉自己，有时这——你知道的，这发生在凌晨三点，这毫无意义。你早上不会觉得精力充沛的。所有的这种焦虑都解决不了任何问题。你有一个非常生动的比喻，来形容这些想法如何在我们的头脑中运作。跟我讲讲那个“讨厌的室友”的比喻吧。是的，所以想象一下，你被困在一个公寓里，和这个室友住在一起，问题在于他是个非常讨人厌的人。他基本上会待在后面的卧室里玩
video games or something but every now and then he would come out and tell you something you should worry about. And as you were falling asleep in your own bedroom, he would come in and tap your shoulder and say, you know, here's something probably you should be angry about. And you would want to eliminate this roommate. You would want to expel him. You might want to do physical violence against him That's kind of what it's like. That's the human experience. You've got this roommate. He's not in a backbed room
电子游戏什么的，但每隔一段时间，他就会出来告诉你一些你该担忧的事。正当你自己的卧室里快要睡着时，他会走过来拍拍你的肩膀说，你知道的，这大概有件事值得你生气。你会想要除掉这个室友。你会想要赶走他。你甚至可能想对动用武力对付他。这有点像是那种感觉。这就是人类的体验。你有这样一个室友。他不在后面的卧室里
He lives in a corner of your mind And comes out to make you miserable That isn't necessarily his goal. He's just thoughtless. It's just what he does. And that's the human experience. So both you and I consider the movie Groundhog Day, one of our all-time favorites. On the surface, it's just another Hollywood romantic comedy. But I want to spend a moment with the movies, since I think it reveals some really interesting philosophical ideas that will inform this conversation.
他住在你脑海的一个角落里，出来让你痛苦不堪。那不一定是他的目标。他只是没心没肺。他就是这样。这就是人类的体验。所以你我都认为电影《土拨鼠之日》是我们历来最喜欢的电影之一。表面上看，它只是又一部好莱坞浪漫喜剧。但我想花点时间聊聊这部电影，因为我认为它揭示了一些非常有趣的哲学思想，这些思想将为我们今天的对话提供启发。
So for the people who haven't watched Groundhog Day, the movie is about Phil Connors. He's a cynical TV weatherman. Out in California, they're going to have some warm weather tomorrow, gang wars, and some very overpriced real estate. He dislikes his colleagues, he hates his job. He's been assigned to cover the groundhog
所以，对于那些没看过《土拨鼠之日》的人来说，这部电影讲的是菲尔·康纳斯的故事。他是一个愤世嫉俗的电视天气预报员。在加州，他们明天会迎来一些暖和的天气，帮派战争，还有一些价格虚高的房地产。他不喜欢同事，讨厌自己的工作。他被指派去报道土拨鼠
day festivities in Punxatani, Pennsylvania. It's the middle of winter, fill things, this is a boring assignment. This is pitiful, a thousand people freezing their butts off, waiting to worship a rat. What a hype. He can't wait to get it over with. But after he finishes filing this lacluster report, bad weather forces him to stay overnight in town and when he wakes up the next day, he discovers that time has rewound itself and he is back at the start of Groundhog Day. He has to do the same TV report, meet the same
日的庆典活动，地点在宾夕法尼亚州的旁苏塔尼。正值隆冬，菲尔觉得，这是一个无聊的任务。这太可悲了，一千个人冻得屁滚尿流，却在顶礼膜拜一只老鼠。真是一场炒作。他恨不得快点结束。但在这篇平淡无奇的报道结束后，恶劣的天气迫使他在镇上过夜，当他第二天醒来时，他发现时间倒流了，他又回到了土拨鼠之日的起点。他必须做同样的电视报道，遇到相同的人，
people, live the same boring day over again. And then the same thing happens the next day and the next and the next, he is living in the prison of Groundhog Day What's going boys? You're playing yesterdays today? Bill tell me if you remember how does Phil react to the setback? He becomes increasingly depressed. Rita, I'm reliving the same day over and over. Groundhog day. I am rack in my brain, but I can't even begin to imagine why you make up something like this.
过着同样无聊的一天。然后第二天、第三天、又是新的一天，同样的事情再次发生，他生活在《土拨鼠之日》的监狱里。伙计们，怎么回事？你们在把昨天当今天过吗？比尔，告诉我，你还记得菲尔对挫折是怎么反应的吗？他变得越来越沮丧。丽塔，我在一遍又一遍地重温同一天。土拨鼠日。我绞尽脑汁，但也无法想象你怎么会编造出这样的事。
I'm not making it up. I am asking you for help. I used to watch the movie Every Groundhog Day until two years ago when my wife said that's enough groundhog day. I think we can skip this year and I think in one scene we finally see him there in his pajamas, playing along with a game where they ask questions. And the problem is he knows all the answers because he's heard it a hundred times before because it's what he starts every day.
我没有编造。我在向你求助。我以前每年土拨鼠日都会看这部电影，直到两年前我妻子说，土拨鼠日够了。我想我们今年可以跳过了。我想在其中一个镜头里，我们终于看到他穿着睡衣，参与一个他们玩问答的游戏。问题是，他知道所有的答案，因为他已经听过一百遍了，因为这就是他每一天开始时的样子。
And that's the interesting thing. That idea that you have to live the same day over and over, it can be a really depressing thought. So at one point in the movie, as the same day endlessly replace itself over and over again, fill boils over with frustration. And his rate spills into the TV segment he's doing and he latches out on camera at his colleagues Larry and Rita. You got a problem with what I'm saying Larry. Untie your tongue and you come out here and talk, huh?
这就是有趣的地方。那种必须一遍又一遍地过着同一天的想法，可能会让人感到非常沮丧。所以在电影的某个时刻，随着同一天无休止地重复再重复，菲尔愤怒得要溢出来了。他的怒火蔓延到了他正在做的电视节目中，他在镜头前对同事拉里和丽塔大发雷霆。我对拉里说的话你有什么意见吗？解开你的舌头，你给我出来说说，嗯？
Am I upsetting you, Princess? You know, you want a prediction about the weather? You're asking the wrong Phil. I'll give you a winter prediction. It's going to be cold. It's going to be gray. And it's going to last you for the rest of your life. So Bill, the comedy comes from the fact that as we watch from the outside, we can see how Phil's reaction to his own suffering is actually making things worse.
我惹你生气了吗，公主？你知道的，你想预测天气吗？你问错菲尔了。我给你做一个冬天的预测。天气会很冷。天会是灰蒙蒙的。而且这种日子会伴随你的余生。所以比尔，喜剧效果来自于：当我们从旁观者角度观看时，我们可以看到菲尔对自身痛苦的反应实际上是如何把事情弄得更糟的。
But he can't see it, can he? No, he can't. He's trapped. He hasn't figured it out. And a lot of people actually haven't figured it out as well. A lot of us normal people that much of the suffering we experience is due to our response to the events of life. And that's a tragedy. You have one life to live. And to spend it living the same day over and over when you have other options open. That's tragic.
但他自己却看不出来，对吧？不，他看不出来。他被困住了。他还没想明白。其实很多人也都没想明白。我们许多正常人所经历的痛苦，很大程度上都源于我们对生活事件的反应。这是一场悲剧。你只有一次生命。当你还有其他选择时，却把生命耗费在日复一日地重复同一天上面。这太悲剧了。
So I want to stay with this core insight for just a moment. You know, all of us think that when the world hands us a lemon, when things go wrong, it's the world's fault, the world is causing us to suffer. But I think a core insight that you just pointed out was that our response to what the world hands us is as much a part of our suffering as what the world gives us. Can you talk about that for a moment? Yeah, actually our response is usually worse. Think about if somebody says something obnoxious to you, those are just words. They're there and gone. What will cause you the agony is you dwelling on those words, thinking about those words, replaying those words. I've known people, older people, in nursing homes homes who had lost much of their memory, you know, dementia
所以我想在这个核心见解上多停留一会儿。你知道，我们所有人都认为，当世界给我们一个柠檬，当事情出错时，那是世界的错，是世界在让我们受苦。但我认为你刚刚指出的一核心见解是：我们对世界施予之事的反应，在我们的痛苦中占据了和世界给予我们的一样大的比重。你能谈谈这个吗？是的，事实上，我们的反应通常更糟。想想如果有人对你说了什么令人讨厌的话，那些只是话语。它们说完就没了。真正折磨你的是你对这些话的念念不忘，对这些话的思考，对这些话的反复回味。我认识一些人，在疗养院里的老年人，他们失去了大部分记忆，你知道的，痴呆症
had set in. And the amazing thing was they could still remember and describe in detail an annoying incident that happened decades ago. It just drills deep into your brain and it has the power to poison your life. And that's what you got to look out for. You have a wonderful analogy of a burst pipe in your home. So when a pipe bursts, you have to quickly shut off the water and call a plumber and then you have to deal with the water damage. Tell me about the analogy between this burst pipe
已经发作了。神奇的是，他们仍然能记住并详细描述几十年前发生的烦恼事件。它深深地钻进你的大脑，并有能力毒害你的生活。这就是你需要警惕的地方。你有一个极好的比喻，关于家里的水管破裂。因此，当水管破裂时，你必须迅速关闭水阀，叫水管工，然后你必须处理水灾造成的损失。跟我讲讲这个爆裂水管
and the way many of us respond to life's setbacks. Yeah, burst pipe is not your problem. A burst pipe, you call a plumber and if the plumber is competent, might take them half an hour to fix it, might cost you a few hundred dollars and it's back to business as normal. The pipe isn't the problem. The problem is all the water that came out of the broken pipe. If this is the second story bedroom where the pipe broke, you could have a collapsed ceiling on the first floor. And that could have damaged the carpet, could have damaged furniture. So we're talking of thousands of dollars worth of damage. We're talking maybe days or weeks of repairs being done until it's finally clear, but that's what? One of life's setbacks is like when somebody insults you. It isn't the insult, that's just words. It's your response to the insult and it can be orders of magnitude
和我们许多人对生活挫折的反应之间的比喻吧。是的，水管破裂本身不是你的问题。水管破了，你叫个水管工，如果水管工靠谱的话，可能花半小时就能修好，可能花你几百美元，然后一切就恢复正常营业了。水管不是问题。问题是从破裂水管里流出来的那一大堆水。如果这是二楼卧室水管破裂，你可能会导致一楼的天花板坍塌。那可能会损坏地毯，可能会损坏家具。所以我们谈论的是价值几千美元的损失。我们谈论的可能是需要几天或几周的维修工作，直到最终清理完毕，但这算什么？生活中的挫折就像有人侮辱你一样。根本不是侮辱本身，那只是些话语。而是你对侮辱的反应，它造成的伤害可能会比侮辱本身大上好几个数量级。
greater harm than the insult itself did. harm that it does you, then the insult itself did. Is it possible that getting stuck in these loops, what psychologists sometimes call perseveration, that some of us are more prone to it than others, and other what some of us have, are more annoying, roommate than others? I think so, and I've given this some thought, and I think there are, you know, dispositions, there are personality types. But I also think it's possible with a little bit of effort and a little bit of direction for you to do as much with whatever personality you were born with in
它对你造成的伤害，比侮辱本身还要大。有没有可能陷入这些循环中——心理学家有时称之为“持续固着”——我们中的有些人比其他人更容易陷入其中，而其他人则拥有比别人更烦人的室友？我想是的，我对此做过思考，我认为确实存在，你知道的，天赋倾向，存在人格类型。但我也认为，只要付出一点点努力和一点点方向指引，你完全可以用你生来俱有的人格，做出很多调整，
terms of redirecting it so that life's setbacks aren't quite as damaging as they otherwise would be. Coming up after the break, we explore the psychological techniques used by as damaging as they otherwise would be. Coming up after the break, we explore the psychological techniques used by people who respond exceptionally well to life's curveballs. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. We've seen how our responses to setbacks can sometimes produce problems that compound the original setback. We can't always control what the world does to us, but in his book, The Stoic Challenge,
以便让生活的挫折不像原本那样具有破坏性。广告之后，我们将探讨那些对生活抛出的曲线球做出极好反应的人所使用的心理技术。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们已经看到，我们对挫折的反应有时会产生使最初挫折雪上加霜的问题。我们无法总是控制世界对我们做什么，但在他的新书《斯多葛式的挑战》中，
philosopher William Irvin says, there's a way to change how we respond to the world. In fact, when we look at many successful and well-adjusted people, we see them practicing the very skills that could lead all of us to greater peace of mind. Bill, in your book you tell the story of the astronaut Neil Armstrong. He's obviously famous for the moon landing, but you describe another incident involving Neil Armstrong. Tell me that story and what lesson you drew from it. Yeah, in order to be able to land on the moon, they needed a lunar lander and they needed to practice landing with it, so they did that on Earth on multiple occasions. It would hover above the ground, maybe a few hundred feet. It was a very, very difficult vehicle to pilot. It's likened to trying to balance a dinner dish on the end of
哲学家威廉·欧文说，有一种方法可以改变我们对世界的反应。事实上，当我们审视许多成功且适应良好的人时，我们会发现他们正在践行那些能够引领我们所有人获得内心平静的技能。比尔，在你的书中，你讲述了宇航员尼尔·阿姆斯特朗的故事。他显然因登月而闻名，但你描述了关于尼尔·阿姆斯特朗的另一个事件。请告诉我那个故事，以及你从中汲取了什么教训。是的，为了能够在月球上着陆，他们需要一个登月舱，并且需要用它练习着陆，所以他们在地球上多次进行了这种练习。它会悬停在地面上方，大概几百英尺的高度。这是一个非常非常难驾驶的交通工具。它就像是试图在
a broom handle, and on one of the times they were testing it. Neil Armstrong had it up and Valve stuck in one of the thrusters and the whole thing started tipping over sideways when it became approximately at a 90 degree angle tipping over. He being a trained pilot, hit the ejector button, blew off the lander, and his parachute automatically opened, he drifted down to Earth safely. Meanwhile, the lander crashed into a big fireball. He had no harm done to him physically, other than I think he bit his tongue,
扫帚柄端平衡一个餐盘，有一次他们在测试时。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗把它升空了，其中一个推进器的阀门卡住了，整个飞行器开始向一侧倾斜，当它倾斜到大约90度角时。身为受过训练的飞行员，他按下了弹射按钮，炸飞了登月舱，他的降落伞自动打开了，他安全地飘回了地面。与此同时，登月舱撞成了一个巨大的火球。他的身体没有受到任何伤害，除了我想他在落地时
when he hit the ground. So later on, he was back at the office complex filling out paperwork as you can imagine someone would have to do after crashing a lunar lander. And fellow astronaut Alan Bing came along and saw him working there. Alan Bing hadn't heard anything about any of this but saw him working there and stuck his head in the office and said, hey, Neil, how are things going? And Neil said, hey, fine. So Alan Bean went on to talk to another astronaut.
咬到了舌头。所以后来，他回到办公室大楼填写文书工作，正如你可以想象的那样，一个人在坠毁了一个登月舱后必须做的事情。同僚宇航员阿伦·宾走了过来，看到他在那里工作。阿伦·宾对这一切一无所知，但看到他在那儿工作，便把头探进办公室说：“嘿，尼尔，情况怎么样？”尼尔说：“嘿，挺好的。”于是阿伦·宾去跟另一位宇航员讲话了。
And the other astronaut said, did you hear what happened this morning? Neil crashed the lander. And at that point, Alan Bean went back to Neil Armstrong and said, you crashed the lander. And Neil said, oh, the lander and Neil said, oh yeah, yeah, you know, those are tippy things and down it went. And didn't have another thing to say about it. So just imagine this life-threatening thing
而另一位宇航员说：“你听说了今天早上发生的事吗？尼尔坠毁了登月舱。”就在那时，阿伦·宾折返回尼尔·阿姆斯特朗身边说：“你把登月舱坠毁了。”尼尔说：“哦，登月舱，”尼尔说，“哦，对啊，对啊，你知道的，那些东西本来就容易倾斜，然后它就掉下去了。”之后就再没提过别的。所以想象一下，经历过这样一件可能危及生命的险情，
he went through it, behaved like a hero and yet didn't even think it was worth mentioning. Just bounced right back as if nothing had happened. That's true. I did. There was work to be done. Right, a minute. It was just almost killed.
他表现得像个英雄，然而却根本不觉得这有什么值得一提的。就像什么都没发生过一样，迅速振作起来。确实如此。是的。还有工作要做。没错，等等。他差点就丧命了。
Well, but I wasn't. Talk about low drama, huh? Yeah, talk about no drama. And yet, that's one approach you can take to things. It's history now, so let's move on and figure out what happens next. There's another story you tell. This one is a 13-year-old sir for a name, Bethany Hamilton. It's instructive in that it shows what you were just talking about a second ago, which
好吧，但我没死啊。真是毫无戏剧性，对吧？是的，谈不上任何戏剧性。然而，这是你可以采取的一种对待事情的方法。这已经成为历史了，所以让我们继续前进，弄清楚接下来会发生什么。你还讲了另一个故事。这是一个13岁的小冲浪手，名叫贝瑟尼·汉密尔顿。这个故事很有启发意义，因为它展示了你刚才谈到的一点，那就是
is some people managed to stay relentlessly focused on the future, rather than fretting about the past. Tell me Bethany's story, Bill. Yeah, Bethany Hamilton was young surfer, a very good surfer, and was out surfing one day with a friend and was there waiting for the next big wave. With her arms draped over the surfboard when suddenly something hit her right arm. And before she knew it, she saw the flash of gray. She realized that it was a shark and she realized that she was missing her right arm.
有些人能够坚定不移地专注于未来，而不是为过去苦恼。比尔，讲讲贝瑟尼的故事吧。是的，贝瑟尼·汉密尔顿是个年轻的冲浪手，冲浪技术非常棒，有一天她和朋友出去冲浪，在那儿等着下一个大浪。她的双臂搭在冲浪板上，突然有什么东西撞了她的右手臂。还没等她反应过来，她就看到了灰色的闪光。她意识到那是一条鲨鱼，并且意识到她的右手臂不见了。
Instead of panicking, she made her way back to shore. She was rushed to an emergency room. But what's of interest here is the way Bethany responded to this tragedy. I think when you're faced with such incredible trials at such a young age, you're just trying to find that light of hope of like, okay, what can I do? What did she do?
她没有惊慌失措，而是设法回到了岸边。她被紧急送往急诊室。但这里引人关注的是贝瑟尼面对这场悲剧的反应。我想，当你在这么小的年纪面对如此不可思议的考验时，你只是在试图寻找希望之光，想着：“好吧，我能做什么？”她做了什么？
She rose to the challenge. As soon as her doctor said it's okay to get wet again. She went out and she taught herself again how to surf. And normally you use two hands pressing down. She had only one hand to push herself up to a standing position. She figured out how to do that. And she also figured out a bunch of other things like how do do you button a shirt? Answer is, you don't. You don't get shirts with buttons.
她迎难而上。一旦医生说可以重新下水了。她就出海了，并重新自学如何冲浪。通常你需要双手向下撑。她只有一只手来把自己撑起到站立姿势。她想出了如何做到这一点。她还想出了许多其他事情，比如怎么系衬衫扣子？答案是，不系。你不要买带扣子的衬衫。
There's a workaround for that. I didn't need easy. I just needed possible. So we see something really strange in people like Neil Armstrong and Bethany Hamilton. When bad things happen to them, they not only don't react the way most of us do, they don't spend a lot of time wishing that the bad thing had not happened to them. I want to play you a clip from Yankee First Basement, Lou Gehrig. He had to retire from baseball near the peak of his career after being diagnosed with
这有替代方案。我不需要轻松，我只需要可行。所以我们在像尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和贝瑟尼·汉密尔顿这样的人身上看到了一些非常奇怪的现象。当不好的事情发生时，他们不仅没有像我们大多数人那样反应，而且他们不会花大量时间去懊恼那件不好的事情不该发生在自己身上。我想放一段洋基队一垒手路·葛里格的音频剪辑。他在肌萎缩侧索硬化症
a myotropic lateral sclerosis. Here's the clip. 1941 at the age of 37, what's the secret these people have in common, Bill? A secret is they realize a few basic insights. One is that history is history. History is over. You can't change history. You can change what happens tomorrow. And another thing, the Stoics actually never said what I'm about to tell you, but I think it could be their motto, do what you can with what you've got, where you are. And if you look at the people that we hold up as this kind of hero who bounced back from extreme setbacks, that's what they did. They did what they could with what they had, where they were.
确诊后，在职业生涯的巅峰期被迫退役。这是那段录音。1941年，年仅37岁，这些人身上有什么共同的秘诀呢，比尔？秘诀在于他们意识到了一些基本的见解。其一是历史就是历史。历史已经结束了。你无法改变历史。你可以改变明天发生的事。还有一点，斯多葛学派实际上从来没有说过我接下来要告诉你的话，但我认为这可以成为他们的座右铭：尽你所能，利用你所有的，待在你所在的地方。如果你看看那些我们在经历极端挫折后能够振作起来的英雄式人物，他们就是这么做的。他们尽其所能，利用他们所拥有的，在他们所在的地方。
And Lou Gehric did that. He remained a hero to the end. That I might have been given a bad phrase, but I've got an awful lot to look for. Thank you. You've spent decades reading about and trying to emulate some of the greatest philosophers who ever lived. I'm wondering if you can tell me the story of Musoneus Rufus. I understand he ran a foul of an emperor and was banished to a desolate island, but survived it in some
路·葛里格就是这样做的。他至死都是个英雄。我或许抽到了一手烂牌，但我有太多值得期待的东西了。谢谢你们。你花了数十年时间阅读并试图效仿历史上最伟大的几位哲学家。我想知道你能否给我讲讲穆索尼乌斯·鲁福斯的故事。据我所知，他得罪了一位皇帝，被流放到一个荒凉的岛屿上，但在某种程度上，他通过汲取塑造了你自身生活的同一哲学传统，在流放中存活了下来。是的，斯多葛学派哲学家有一个不幸的倾向，那就是容易惹恼当权者并遭到流放。因此，几位最著名的斯多葛学派哲学家都度过了一段被流放的时光。你被发配到一个岛上。穆索尼乌斯被送往的岛屿是其中一个特别糟糕的岛屿，爱琴海上的希腊小岛雅罗斯。它被描述为一块荒凉的岩石。他去了那里，发现它并非无人居住，
ways by drawing on the same philosophical tradition that is informed your own life. Yeah, the Stoic philosophers had an unfortunate tendency to get in trouble with the powers that be and to be banished by them. So several of the most famous Stoics spent time banished. You get sent out to an island. And the island that Musonius was sent to was one of the particularly bad islands, the Greek island of Yaros in the Aegean Sea. It's described as a desolate rock. He went there and discovered that it wasn't uninhabited, that
那里有零星几个渔民，他们想出了在岛上谋生的方法。所以他做的是，他把时间花在岛上，研究这个岛。他在岛上发现了一个当地人不知道的新泉水。他的学生们不时上岛探望他，他们以为自己是来安慰他的。而当他们到达时，他反而去安慰他们，倾听他们的烦恼，因为他是怎么做的？他尽其所能，利用他所拥有的，在当时他所在的地方。他是非正义的目标，却拒绝扮演受害者的
there were a handful of fishermen who figured out a way to make a living there. So what he did is he spent his time on the island, studying the island. He found a new spring on the island that the locals didn't know about. He was visited from time to time on the island by his students, and they thought they were coming to cheer him up. He would cheer them up when they got there and listened to their problems because what did he do? He did what he could with what he had where he was. He was the target of injustice and yet refused to play the role of victim of
角色。这完全是另一种心态。受害者可能会沉溺于自怜之中，而目标则会振作起来思考：接下来我该怎么做，才能把这种针对给我造成的伤害降到最低？因此，他践行了三种技术来将受到的伤害降到最低。我想逐一讨论它们，因为我认为它们蕴含着深刻的心理学见解。第一种与理解什么是你能控制的、什么是你不能控制的有关。比尔，谈谈这个想法吧。是的，这就是控制二分法，
injustice. It's a different mindset altogether. A victim might wallow in self-pity, a target rises and thinks, what am I going to do next in order to minimize the harm that this targeting has done to me? So there were three techniques that he practiced to minimize the harm that was done to him. And I want to discuss them one by one, because I think they carry deep psychological insight. The first has to do with an understanding of what he could control and what he couldn't control. Talk about this idea, Bill. Yes, this is the dichotomy of control,
虽然在我自己的著作中，我把它拆解成了控制三分法。所以你拥有完全控制权的事情，那些会是你的价值观，会是你做出的选择。你完全无法控制的事情，比如明天太阳是否会升起。因此，第一条建议，斯多葛学派的建议，来自于穆索尼乌斯的学生爱比克泰德，他是四位伟大的罗马斯多葛学派哲学家之一。给出的建议是：不要把时间花在思考你无法控制的事情上，因为你无法控制它们。这是在浪费时间。你应当把时间
although in my own works, I've broken it into a tri-cotomy of control. So things you have complete control over, those would be your values, those would be the choices that you make. Things you have no control over at all are like whether the sun rises tomorrow. So the first bit of advice, stoic advice, and this comes from Eusonius's student Epictetus, one of the four great Roman stoic philosophers. The advice is don't spend your time thinking about things you have no control over because you can't control them. It's a waste of time. You should instead
花在非常仔细地思考你确实有控制权的事情上，包括你的价值观。然后是这个有趣的中间类别，也就是你拥有部分但不是完全控制权的类别。比如我使用的一个比喻是为网球比赛做准备。你无法控制你的对手练习有多刻苦，你无法控制比赛当天的天气状况，但有些事情你是可以控制的，比如你训练有多刻苦，比如你为比赛制定的策略。这就是你应该集中注意力的地方。在这里我稍微岔开一下。当一个斯多葛学派信徒完成比赛后，无论他是在为比赛做什么准备，他都不会以输赢来评判自己。
spend that time thinking very carefully about things you do have control over, including your values. And then there's this interesting middle category and that's the category of things you have some but not complete control over. So one analogy I use is preparing for a tennis match. You can't control how hard your opponent practices, you can't control the weather conditions on the day of the match, but there are things you can control like how hard you train, like the strategy you come up with for doing the match. And that's what you should be focusing your attention on. Let me take a little bit of a side trip here. When a stoic has finished, whenever he was preparing for his over, he won't judge himself on the basis of whether he won or lost.
他会根据自己是否充分利用了手头可用的资源来评判自己。如果他做到了，那就是成功，因为那是他唯一能做到的，你知道的，用某种更高的标准来衡量成功，简直是纯粹的疯狂。穆索尼乌斯在那个荒凉的小岛上践行的第二种技术，是提醒自己事情本可以更糟糕。他为什么要这么做？他又做了什么，比尔？是的，这是一种被称为“锚定”的现象，无论你处于什么情况，它是好是坏？这得看情况。这取决于什么？
He'll judge himself on whether he did the most with what he had available to him. And if he did that, that's success, because that's all he could do, you know, to measure success by some higher standard, is sheer lunacy. The second technique that Musonea's practiced on this desolate island was to remind himself that things could have been much worse. Why did he do this and what did he do, Bill? Yeah, this is a phenomenon known as anchoring and whatever situation you're in is it good or bad? Well, it depends. It depends on what.
这取决于你把它和什么进行比较。例如，你知道的，我们正在经历这场新冠大流行。很多人问我：在这种情况下，一个斯多葛学派会怎么做？我建议说，嗯，他们会做的一件事就是玩这种锚定游戏，他们会去想事情可能会变得多糟。你知道，这很有趣，因为我的学生说，现在事情已经坏到头了。然后我给他们讲了二战期间伦敦大轰炸的故事。
It depends on what you're comparing it to. So for instance, you know, we're going through this COVID pandemic. I've been asked by many people, so what would a stoic do under these circumstances? And I suggested, well, one of the things they would do is they would do this game of anchoring and they would think about how things could be worse. And you know, it's interesting because my students said, now this is as bad as things get. And then I tell them the story of the blitz in London during World War II.
日夜不息，夜以继日，无差别的空袭持续着。不是你被反锁在公寓里，而是你每天晚上都必须离开公寓。在地下避难所里，永不屈服的英国人继续前进。走进地铁隧道，和300个陌生人睡在地上。第二天早上起来，回到你的公寓
Night and day, day and night, in discriminative attacks continue. Where it wasn't that you were locked into your apartment, it was that you had to leave your apartment every night. In underground shelters, a don't-list Britain carries on undismade. Go into a subway tunnel and sleep with 300 strangers on the ground. Get up the next morning and go back to your apartment
祈祷它在前一天晚上没有被炸成一堆瓦砾。历史上从来没有一个整全的民族经受过如此可怕、如此严峻的考验。你知道的，一旦你把它放进那个框架里，你就会开始觉得，你知道的，这其实也没那么糟嘛。穆索尼乌斯和其他斯多葛学派哲学家推荐的第三种技术，是通过偶尔的自我克制行为来学习自我控制。比尔，他们这是什么意思？是的，这就是我所说的斯多葛式训练。
in the hopes that it hadn't been bombed into a rubble the night before. Never in history as an entire people born so frightful and ordeal so gravely. You know, and once you put it into that frame, then you start thinking, you know, this isn't so bad after all. The third technique that Musoneas and other stoic philosophers have recommended is to learn self-control through occasional acts of self-denial. What do they mean by this bill? Yeah, this is what I call stoic training.
我喜欢把它比作你的免疫系统。我们都知道我们的生物免疫系统。它是做什么的？它对抗病菌。它对抗病毒。有趣的是，除非你锻炼你的生物免疫系统，否则它就无法正常运转。我认识一个儿科医生，我问他孩子们是否应该接触泥土。他的回答是：是的，小孩子应该吃一磅泥土。好吧，不是一次性吃完，但你知道的，如果孩子在屋里走来走去，想舔舔桌子，就让他舔舔桌子吧。你知道的，养宠物。
I like to think of it in terms of your immune system. We all know about our biological immune system. What does it do? Well, it fights off germs. It fights off viruses. And the interesting thing is, unless you develop your biological immune system, it's not going to function properly. I know a pediatrician, and I asked him about whether children should be exposed to dirt. And his answer was, yeah, kid should eat a pound of dirt. Well, not in a single sitting, but you know what, if the kid is walking around the house and wants to suck on the table, let him suck on the table. You know, get pets.
宠物会很脏。这很好，因为你想让他的生物免疫系统得到发育。斯多葛学派没有用这些术语思考，因为他们对免疫系统一无所知，但这真是一个很好的平行对照。你有一个情感免疫系统，但你需要训练它，你训练它的方式就是去经历那些会让你不快乐的事情。你特意去经历这些事情，仅仅是因为这样做会锻炼你的情感免疫系统。所以想想一个住在宫殿里的人。想想一个从不出任何差错的人。
The pets are going to be dirty. That's good because you want him to develop his biological immune system. The Stoics didn't think in these terms because they didn't know about immune systems, but it's a nice parallel. You have an emotional immune system, but you need to train it, and the way you train it is by experiencing things that are going to make you unhappy. You go out of your way to experience those things just because doing so will develop your emotional immune system. So think about somebody who lives in a palace. Think about somebody who never has anything go wrong.
只需要最小的挫折，那个人就会彻底崩溃。相比之下，想想另一个人，他总是出去尝试做那些会让自己身体感到不适、情绪感到不适的事情，给这样的人提供某种挑战，他们就会泰然处之。我想知道有些人听了你的话，可能会把你的话当成某种形式的“煤气灯操纵”（精神虐待）。
All it will take is the smallest little setback and that person is going to be a basket case. Think about somebody instead who's always going out and trying to do things that are going to make him physically uncomfortable, that are going to make him emotionally uncomfortable, present that person with a challenge of some kind, and they're going to take it in their stride. I'm wondering if some people might hear what you're saying and sort of think of what you're saying as a form of gaslighting.
我是这个意思。因为实际上，我们可能在告诉人们：是的，你的生活很糟糕；是的，可怕的事情发生在你身上了。但如果你不快乐，那就是你的错，因为你没有对挫折做出正确的反应。斯多葛主义会不会有一种风险，演变成一种“责怪受害者”的现象？我们确实可能会这么做。
And here's what I mean. Because effectively, what we might be telling people is, yes, your life sucks, yes, terrible things have happened to you. But if you're unhappy, it's your fault because you are not reacting properly to your setbacks. Is there a risk that stoicism can sort of transfer over into the phenomenon of blaming the victim? We could do that.
我的意思是，可以这样来表达：如果你看看古典时期的斯多葛学派，他们认为如果你想过上幸福的生活，如果你想过一种作为人能够蓬勃发展的生活，在某种程度上，你必须对那种生活承担责任。话虽如此，生活中确实有些事情是你无法控制的，总会有这些糟糕的事情发生在你身上。那你要怎么办？你尽你所能去应对它们。但斯多葛学派的核心见解是：它们对你造成的绝大多数伤害，并非事件本身，而是你对事件的反应。
I mean, here's one way to put it. If you look at the classical stoics, they thought that if you want to have a happy life, if you want to have a life in which you flourish as a human being, there is an extent to which you have to take responsibility for that life. Now, that said, there are things in life you can't control, and there are going to be these bad things that come up and happen to you. So what do you do? You deal with them to the best of your ability. But the stoic insight was, most of the damage that they do to you is not the event itself, but your reaction to the event.
所以你需要做的是，想出一个办法将这种反应控制在一定范围内。你知道的，如果你看看那些我们钦佩的人，比如马丁·路德·金，他曾是严重歧视的目标。但他拒绝扮演受害者的角色。他找到了一个方法来把这件事对他的个人伤害降到最低。通过这种方式，他可以把本会花在自我击垮、感到无能为力上的精力节省下来，把这些精力用来发起一场运动。所以，当你成为邪恶和恶意力量的目标时，这是一个极好的方向，一个你可以采取的重定向。
And so what you need to do is figure out a way to keep that reaction within certain bounds. You know, and if you look at people, we admire, if you look at Martin Luther King, for example, he was the target of considerable discrimination. He refused to play the role of victim. He found a way to minimize the harm it did him personally. And that way he could use the energy that he would have spent feeling, beat down, feeling powerless, he used that energy to start a movement. So that's a wonderful direction, a redirection you can take when you have been targeted by evil and malicious forces.
我想给你读一下牛津词典对“斯多葛主义”（Stoicism）的定义。它说这是对痛苦或苦难的忍耐，不表露情感，也不抱怨。而Dictionary.com则说斯多葛主义是关于压抑情感。这些定义准确吗？因为如果是这样的话，听起来一点也不吸引人，也一点都不好玩。是的，我大半生都在回避斯多葛主义，正是出于这个原因。然后大约15年前，我在做一个研究项目，我突然意识到，这是人们常有的一个观念，但却非常错误。所以在我的写作中，我区分了我所说的小写s和大写S的斯多葛主义。小写s斯多葛主义正是你刚才所说的。所以一个小
I want to read you the Oxford Dictionary Definition of Stoicism. It says it's the endurance of pain or hardship, without the display of feelings and without complaint. And dictionary.com says Stoicism is about the repression of emotion. Are those definitions accurate? Because if so, it doesn't sound like it's very appealing or very fun. Yeah, I avoided stoicism for most of my life for just that reason. And then about 15 years ago, I was in a research project and it dawned on me that it's a common idea people have, but it's very mistaken. So in my own writing, I distinguish between what I call lowercase s and uppercase s stoicism. Lowercase s stoicism is precisely what you just said. So a lower
写s的斯多葛主义者是一个站在那里，逆来顺受地接受生活抛给他的任何东西，并且在这个过程中不表达情绪的人。但罗马的斯多葛主义者是大写S的斯多葛主义者。并不是说他们压抑情感。而是他们试图避免体验负面情绪——诸如愤怒、焦虑、挫折、嫉妒等情绪，但他们并不反对积极情绪，包括欣喜的感觉，甚至包括快乐。这才是最不可思议的地方。
case s stoic is a person who stands there and simply takes whatever life has to throw at him and doesn't express emotions in the process. But the Roman stooics were uppercase S-Stoics. It isn't that they suppressed emotion. It's that they tried to avoid experiencing negative emotions, emotions like anger, anxiety, frustration, envy, but they had nothing against positive emotions, including feelings of delight, including even joy. That's the incredible thing.
如果你去了解古代斯多葛主义者的实际生活，他们其实以性格开朗而闻名。这与你的预期完全相反。这种误解我认为让很多人与一种本可以对他们的现实生活大有帮助的信条保持了距离。我们在《隐藏大脑》的不同分集中，详细讨论过享乐适应的现象，也就是当美妙的事情发生在你身上，美好的事物进入你的生活时，我们很快就会习惯它们，
If you actually look into the lives of the ancient Stoics, they had a reputation for being cheerful individuals. It's an absolute opposite of what you would expect. One that I think keeps a lot of people distanced from a doctrine that could be very helpful to them in the life that they're living. We've talked at length on Hidden Brain in various episodes about the phenomenon of the hedonic treadmill, which is you have wonderful things happen to you, good things come into your life, and very quickly we get habituated to them
而没有真正认清它们的价值，我们开始把它们视为理所当然。斯多葛主义者会如何去放大积极面呢？特别是当积极的事物一直环绕在她身边，当她无时无刻不在看到它们的时候？是的，所以一个斯多葛学派理解——他们虽然没有使用这个词——但他们理解享乐适应。我喜欢把它重新表述为“幸福的差距理论”。
and we fail to see them for what they are, we start to take them for granted. How would a stoic accentuate the positive, especially when the positive is all around her all the time, where she's seeing it all the time? Yeah, so a stoic understands they didn't use this term for it, but they understand the hedonic treadmill. And I like to rephrase it as the gap theory of happiness.
许多人不快乐，是因为他们意识到了自己拥有之物与想要之物之间存在差距。他们坚信，只要能把生活提高一个层级，得到自己想要的东西，幸福就会降临。事实上，这也确实是真的。他们幸福了。有一会儿，几分钟，一小时，几天，然后他们又回到了原来的地方，因为他们发现还有一个更高的层级。他们想，要是我能达到那个层级，我终于就会幸福了。斯多葛学派有的见解——顺便说一句，佛教徒也有，历史上有很多群体都有过同样的见解——那就是，还有第二种方法来缩小这个差距。你需要做的是，学会去渴望你已经拥有的东西。因为这样一来，就没有需要缩小的差距了，你已经到达那里了。
A lot of people are unhappy because they recognize the existence of a gap between what they have and what they want. In their convinced that happiness will come to them if only they can raise that one level and get the thing they want. And in fact, it's true. They are happy. For a while, for a few minutes, for an hour, for days, and then the right back where they were before, because they discovered that there's another level that's even higher. And they think, if only I could reach that level, I would at last be happy. The insight, which the Stoics had, and by the way, the Buddhist sad, and there have been a number of groups in history that have had the same insight is that there's a second way to close the gap. What you need to do is to learn how to want what you already have. Because then there's no gap to close, you're already there.
很多人感到不快乐，是因为他们意识到了自己拥有的和自己想要的东西之间存在差距。他们坚信，只要能提升到那个水平并得到想要的东西，幸福就会降临。事实上也确实如此。他们快乐了。持续了一会儿，几分钟，一小时，几天，然后又回到了原来的状态，因为他们发现还有一个更高的层次。他们认为，只要能达到那个水平，他们最终就会快乐。斯多葛学派以及佛教徒（顺便说一下，历史上还有许多其他群体）都有这样一种洞察：即存在第二种弥合差距的方法。你需要做的是学会去渴望你已经拥有了的东西。因为那样就没有需要弥合的差距了，你已经到达了终点。
Okay, but how do you accomplish that? In the stoic said, you do these certain exercises, these certain psychological strategies, so that you can convince yourself to want the things that you already have. And is one of those things in some ways to remind yourself of the things that could be much worse? We talked about the idea in some ways of exposing yourself to negative phenomena or imagining perhaps that the thing that you have is no longer with you. You imagine the loss of the thing that you actually have
好吧，但你要怎么做到这一点呢？斯多葛学派认为，你要做某些特定的练习，某些特定的心理策略，这样你就能说服自己去渴望你已经拥有的东西。其中一件事在某种程度上是提醒自己那些可能会变得更糟的事情吗？我们讨论过在某种程度上让自己接触负面现象，或者想象你拥有的东西可能已经不在了。你想象你实际拥有的东西失去了
in order to remind yourself of the value of the thing that you have. Yeah, so that's what is referred to as negative visualization. And so if you want to find out what in life you're taking for granted, think about the things in your life that you value and it could be your job, it could be your spouse, it could be your children. So negative visualization is this process in which you give yourself a few seconds to imagine that the thing you value somehow disappears from your life. So you don't dwell on losing the things that you value, but you allow yourself to have a flickering thought about it. You imagine and you try to visualize your life with that person or that thing missing. Just a few seconds and then you get back to life. And when you next encounter the person or thing,
为了提醒自己你所拥有东西的价值。是的，这就是所谓的负面可视化。所以，如果你想找出生活中你在理所当然享受的东西，想想生活中你珍视的东西，它可能是你的工作，可能是你的配偶，可能是你的孩子。因此，负面可视化是一个过程，在这个过程中，你给自己几秒钟的时间，想象你珍视的东西不知何故从你的生活中消失了。所以你不会纠结于失去你珍视的东西，但你允许自己对它有一个一闪而过的想法。你想象并试图在脑海中勾勒出那个你爱的人或那件东西不在了的生活。只需几秒钟，然后你回到生活中。当你下次遇到这个人或那件东西时，
an interesting phenomenon, you will probably notice and that is that you will appreciate them. You're happy to see them. Well, I do this periodically a few times a day. My wife knows that I've been up to negative visualization when she hears me shout out from the back bedroom that's my office. a visualization when she hears me shout out from the back bedroom that's my office. Thank you for existing. And as a result, I realize, gosh, you know, I've really got it good. It's so insidious this process of as soon as you've got something, feels good at first, then you take it for granted. And if you could only appreciate the things you already had, you could really extract the joy that they can provide your life with. Same is true of children.
一个有趣的现象，你可能会注意到，那就是你会感激他们。你很高兴见到他们。嗯，我定期这样做，一天几次。我妻子知道我在进行负面可视化，当她听到我在那间作为我办公室的后卧室里大喊大叫时。可视化，当她听到我在那间作为我办公室的后卧室里大喊大叫时。谢谢你存在。结果，我意识到，天哪，你知道，我真的过得很好。这个过程太隐蔽了，一旦你得到了什么，一开始感觉很好，然后你就把它当成理所当然的了。如果你能感激你已经拥有的东西，你就能真正榨取出它们能为你的生活带来的快乐。对孩子来说也是如此。
You know, there are people who dream of having children, they have them, and then before long start ignoring them and start complaining about them. But imagine that tonight at bedtime, it wasn't possible for you to tell your kid a bedtime story because your kid's off in the hospital or somewhere else. It can change your attitude dramatically in a very short period of time. ["Dramatic Music"] You point out something quite wonderful in the book, which is of course every one of
你知道，有些人梦想有孩子，他们有了孩子，但不久之后就开始忽视他们，开始抱怨他们。但是想象一下，今晚临睡前，你不可能给你的孩子讲睡前故事，因为你的孩子在医院或其他地方。它可以在很短的时间内极大地改变你的态度。“[戏剧性的音乐]”你在书中指出了相当美妙的一点，那就是当然每一个
the things that we have at some level is transient. The possessions we have, the relationships we have, the life that we have, it is fundamentally transient. And in some ways, when you remind yourself of that transient, at the one level, it is potentially scary and upsetting, but it also causes you to pay more attention to the things that you have. So if I remind myself, I'm talking to my friend, but I want to briefly visualize a point
我们拥有的东西在某种程度上都是短暂的。我们拥有的财产，我们拥有的关系，我们拥有的生活，它从根本上说是短暂的。在某种程度上，当你提醒自己这种短暂性时，在一个层面，它可能是潜在的吓人和令人不安的，但它也促使你更多地关注你拥有的东西。所以如果我提醒自己，我正在和我的朋友说话，但我想简短地想象一个时间点
when this person might no longer be my friend or might no longer be in my life, I will engage with my friend more deeply in that conversation that I'm having with him or her today. Then if I sort of essentially took it for granted and assumed that this is a relationship that would last forever. Yeah, then I call it the last-time meditation. It's a great way to put yourself in the moment. You can feel what it's like to be living in the moment. And what you do is whatever it is you're
这个人可能不再是我的朋友，或者可能不再出现在我的生活中，我会更深入地参与到今天我和他或她的对话中。然后，如果我基本上把它视为理所当然，并假设这段关系会永远持续下去。是的，然后我称之为“最后一次冥想”。这是一个让自己融入当下的好方法。你可以感受到活在当下的感觉。你所做的是无论你是什么
doing, you imagine that it's the last time you will ever do it. And for everything you do, there will be a last time that you do it. And that's simply because you're a mortal being. You will someday die. There will be a last time you eat dinner. There will be a last time you lay your head on a pillow. There will be a last breath that you take. Now again, you don't want to go overboard on this because if that's all you think about, you're going to be a miserable human being. But if you occasionally allow yourself to have that thought, then you find it has this psychologically transformative power. You can take what you're doing and you can realize, you know, if this were the last time
在做这件事，你想象这是你最后一次做这件事。对于你做的每一件事，都会有最后一次你做这件事的时候。这很简单，因为你是一个终有一死的存在。你总有一天会死。这将是你最后一次吃晚餐。这将是你最后一次把头枕在枕头上。这将是你最后一次呼吸。再说一次，你不想在这上面走得太远，因为如果这就是你所想的一切，你就会成为一个悲惨的人。但如果你偶尔允许自己有这样的想法，你就会发现它具有这种心理上的变革力量。你可以把你正在做的事拿来，然后你就会意识到，你知道，如果这是最后一次
I was doing this, I would savor this thing that I'm doing. It can be something quite ordinary. You know, I find when I mow the lawn on a hot summer day, I'd like to remind myself that there will be a last time I mow the lawn. There's going to be a time when I'm in a nursing home somewhere, can't mow the lawn. And if I reach that stage, I'm gonna be looking back on that
如果我在做这件事，我会细细品味我正在做的这件事。这可以是一件很普通的事。你知道，我发现当我在炎热的夏天修剪草坪时，我喜欢提醒自己，这将是我最后一次修剪草坪。总有一天我会住在某个养老院里，不能修剪草坪。如果我到了那个阶段，我会回首那个
moment of me out there pushing a lawn more around and it's gonna count as the good old days and you know just that that thought Carly Simon saying it well you know these are the good old days if you live long enough there's a very good chance that these are the good old days. Wouldn't it be tragic for you not to savor them while they're here? The Stoics understood that you don't achieve tranquility by understanding theories about how the mind works. Philosopher William Irvin has learned he needs to practice
我推着割草机到处走的时刻，那将被视为美好的旧时光，你知道，仅仅是那个想法，卡莉·西蒙唱得很好，你知道，这些都是美好的旧时光，如果你活得够久，很有可能这些就是美好的旧时光。如果在它们还在的时候不细细品味，难道不是很悲惨吗？斯多葛学派明白，你不会通过理解关于心灵如何运作的理论来获得宁静。哲学家威廉·欧文了解到他需要练习
a series of techniques to respond well to life's setbacks. Those techniques might help you as well. That's coming up right after the break. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The Stoic philosophers understood that no matter what challenges life throws at us, we have an option. It's up to us to decide how we respond to those challenges. Our responses shape how badly we are affected by setbacks.
一系列的技术来很好地应对生活中的挫折。这些技术对你可能也有帮助。广告之后马上回来。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。斯多葛学派哲学家明白，无论生活给我们带来什么挑战，我们都有一个选择。由我们来决定如何应对这些挑战。我们的反应决定了我们受挫折影响的程度。
They shape how we respond. In important ways, our responses to setbacks shape whether they appear as setbacks at all. Philosopher William Irvin is the author of the book The Stoic Challenge. In it, he explores various techniques to change how he responds to setbacks. Bill, you've come up with a clever game that you play when you are dealing with frustrations. In your book, you describe a horrendous flight with a connection in Chicago. Tell me what went wrong on that flight and how you employed an unusual form of conversation to reshape your response to the setback.
它们决定了我们的反应。在重要方面，我们对挫折的反应决定了它们是否算作挫折。哲学家威廉·欧文是《斯多葛式的挑战》一书的作者。在书中，他探讨了改变自己对挫折反应的各种技术。比尔，当你面对挫折时，你想出了一个巧妙的游戏。在你的书中，你描述了一次在芝加哥转机的可怕飞行。告诉我那次航班出了什么问题，以及你是如何运用一种不寻常的对话形式来重塑你对挫折的反应的。
Back in the day, the good old days before a COVID, I did a fair amount of flying and I was flying cross country and I was in Chicago and the plane I was on, you know, we boarded and got on, they announced that there was a problem loading the luggage, that they were having trouble closing the cargo door. And so they said off the plane, and we're going to find a different plane for you. So you can imagine the groaning that was going on. Everybody goes back into the airport and are sitting there waiting for an announcement,
过去，在新冠肺炎疫情之前的美好旧时光里，我经常坐飞机，当时我正横穿美国本土，我在芝加哥，我坐的那架飞机，你知道，我们登机坐好后，他们广播说行李装载出了问题，他们很难关上货舱门。所以他们让我们下了飞机，我们要为你找另一架飞机。所以你可以想象当时大家的抱怨声。每个人都回到候机楼里，坐在那里等待广播，
and the announcement finally comes on. And the announcement is, sorry, there is no other plane available for tonight. So in the morning, you'll be able to fly out and we'll put you up in a hotel overnight. Huge groaning from all around complaints, people going up to the desk to say, you know, this is not acceptable. But for me, as a practicing stoic,
广播终于响了。广播说，抱歉，今晚没有其他飞机可用。所以明天你就能飞了，我们会在夜里为你安排一家酒店。周围一片巨大的抱怨声，人们走到柜台前说，你知道，这是不可接受的。但对于我来说，作为一个实践中的斯多葛主义者，
it triggered a different response altogether. So I have this thing I call the stoic test game. When I experience a setback, I imagine that what's happened is stoic gods have provided me with a challenge. Now, do I actually believe stoic gods exist? The answer is no. They're imaginary beings. Next question is, why would they inflict these tests on me answer because they want me to thrive, because they want me to be strong, and they want me to be resilient. So they test me.
它引发了完全不同的反应。所以我有个东西叫斯多葛测试游戏。当我经历挫折时，我想象发生的事情是斯多葛诸神给了我一个挑战。现在，我真的相信斯多葛诸神存在吗？答案是没有。它们是虚构的存在。下一个问题是，为什么他们要把这些测试强加给我？答案是因为他们希望我繁荣，因为他们希望我坚强，他们希望我有韧性。所以他们考验我。
You can think of them like a good coach. You know, a good coach won't pamper his or her players. A good coach will try to toughen up the players so they can thrive in upcoming competitions. Why do this mental game and the answer is instead of getting angry, for instance, you think of it as a challenge and you think I can actually do quite well in this. challenge and you think I can actually do quite well in this and you kind of hijack your inner emotions, you want to get angry, but now you've got something else to focus on. And that is to find a workaround for the setback and not get upset in the process. So you have all these people in the airport sitting, groaning, complaining, walking up to the counter,
你可以把他们想象成一个好教练。你知道，一个好教练不会娇惯他的队员。一个好教练会试着让队员变得坚强，这样他们就能在接下来的比赛中蓬勃发展。为什么要玩这个心理游戏？答案是，与其生气，比如，你把它当作一个挑战，然后你想我其实可以做得很好。挑战，你认为你真的可以把这个做好，你有点劫持了你内心的情绪，你想生气，但现在你有其他的事情要关注了。那就是为挫折找到一个变通的办法，在这个过程中不要心烦意乱。所以机场里所有这些人坐着、抱怨、发牢骚、走向柜台，
saying it's unacceptable. You're sitting in your seat having a quiet conversation with the stoic gods. And what did you say to them and what did you say to them in that moment? You know, I actually think these these imaginary stoic gods, I think a lot of them like to hang out in airports because that seems to be where all sorts of setbacks happen. But I'd say this is a clever challenge, but I'm up for it. So bring it on. It's a psychologically useful game. So the airline transfers you to a hotel for the evening because there are no planes available for that day. Does all go smoothly once you get to the hotel? I got to the room, I opened the door and realized that the room had not been made up from the previous person who had stayed there.
说这是不可接受的。你坐在座位上，和斯多葛诸神进行着安静的对话。你对他们说了什么，在那一刻你对他们说了什么？你知道，我真的认为这些虚构的斯多葛诸神，我觉得他们中的很多人喜欢在机场闲逛，因为那似乎是各种挫折发生的地方。但我会说这是一个聪明的挑战，但我准备好了。放马过来吧。这是一个心理上有用的游戏。因此，由于当天没有飞机可用，航空公司将你转到一家酒店过夜。你到了酒店一切都顺利吗？我到了房间，打开门，意识到房间没有按照前一个住过的人清理过。
Psy had back out into the hallway, go all the way back down and tell the person at the desk, hey, you know, the room isn't made up. And so he says, oh, that's funny. And he says, try this one, gives me a different key. Go back up. Now, again, if I weren't a practicing stoic, this would have been when my anger would be at its maximum, you know, the incompetence of this person.
只好回到走廊里，一路走回去告诉前台的人，嘿，你知道，房间没有打扫。所以他说，哦，真有趣。然后他说，试试这个，给了我一把不同的钥匙。再上去。现在，再说一次，如果我不是一个实践中的斯多葛主义者，这将会是我的愤怒达到顶峰的时候，你知道，这个人的无能。
But I took a different spin on it, you know, and again, I tipped my different spin on it, you know, and again I tipped my hat to the stoic odds of, well played, I simply did not see this happening. But, you know, to pass one of these stoic tests, to pass one of these challenges, the trick is to keep your cool. If you don't let it crush you, it's going to strengthen you. You bounce, you don't let it crush you, it's going to strengthen you. Your bounce, you don't break. I want to focus on one of the challenges we have in trying to implement a philosophy like this.
但我对它有了不同的看法，你知道，再一次，我向斯多葛诸神脱帽致敬，玩得漂亮，我根本没料到会发生这种事。但是，你知道，要通过这些斯多葛测试之一，要通过这些挑战之一，诀窍是保持冷静。如果你不让它压垮你，它就会让你变得强大。你反弹，你不让它压垮你，它就会让你变得强大。你反弹，你不会崩溃。我想关注我们在试图实施这样一种哲学时面临的挑战之一。
And in fact, I want to go back to the story you told at the top about being woken up from a nap and hearing the robocall and having to try and deal with a telemarketer. When setbacks arise in our life, when frustrations arise, it seems like the journey between the setback and our, you know, our rage or despair, you know, is almost instantaneous.
事实上，我想回到你在开头讲的那个故事，关于从午睡中醒来，听到机器人电话，不得不应付电话推销员。当生活中的挫折出现时，当沮丧出现时，挫折与我们（你知道的）愤怒或绝望之间的旅程似乎几乎是瞬间发生的。
That we just go from zero to 90 miles an hour in like a second and it happens like that. And there's no time to stop and actually say, the Stoic Gods are testing me. This is a challenge. Can I rise to that challenge? Can you talk a little bit about this idea that in some ways part of the challenge here is not just in coming up with that game but being able to insert the game in the millisecond before your emotion sort of rise up and swallow you up and sweep you away? Yeah, in a stoic challenge book, I describe what I call the five-second rule. It's a nice thing to keep in mind because my own experience with anger is that you
我们就像在一秒钟内从零加速到90英里每小时，事情就这样发生了。根本没有时间停下来实际说一句：斯多葛诸神在考验我。这是一个挑战。我能迎接这个挑战吗？你能谈谈这个想法吗？在某种程度上，这里的挑战不仅在于想出那个游戏，还在于能够在你的情绪涌现、吞噬你并把你卷走之前的毫秒内插入这个游戏？是的，在《斯多葛式的挑战》一书中，我描述了我所说的“五秒钟法则”。这是一个很好的记住的事情，因为我个人对愤怒的体验是，你
need to nip it in the bud. You need to get to it quickly. So I describe five seconds and I don't know if that's the exact time. But if you let the anger burst into flames, you've got a real problem on your hands because it's going to burn, it's going to burn for a long time, even if you reduce it to smoldering, it will burst into flames again, like happened to me on the Sahara Desert. And so the best thing is to prevent it from even being activated to begin with. And that's why you have to be quick. And you get, you develop your instincts on this. So that when a setback comes along, you very quickly put it into the proper frame. You say, this is a test by the stoic gods.. I'm atop my game and I'm going to show the
需要把它扼杀在萌芽状态。你需要迅速采取行动。所以我描述了五秒钟，我不知道这是否是确切的时间。但如果你让愤怒燃烧成火焰，你的手头就会有一个真正的问题，因为它会燃烧，它会燃烧很长时间，即使你把它减少到闷烧，它也会再次燃起大火，就像我在撒哈拉沙漠上发生的那样。所以最好的办法是从一开始就防止它被激活。这就是为什么你必须迅速。你对此培养了你的直觉。因此，当挫折来临时，你很快地把它放在合适的框架里。你说，这是斯多葛诸神的考验。我处于最佳状态，我要向
Stoic Gods what I'm made of. So here's a thought for you. Give it a try. You know, put it to work in your life. Test drive it. And if it doesn't work for you, you've lost very little. And if it does work for you, you've acquired a very important psychological tool. You're talking the book about the value of humor in combating the challenges that the Stoic Gods put in front of us. So in some ways of laughing or mocking in some ways the setbacks that I put before us as a way to counter them. Can you talk about that idea for a moment? Yeah, if you can laugh off an insult, the insult ceases to be a problem for you.
斯多葛诸神展示我是什么料。所以这里有一个想法给你。试一试。你知道，把它运用到你的生活中。试驾一下。如果它对你不管用，你损失很少。如果它对你管用，你就获得了一个非常重要的心理工具。你在书中谈到了幽默在对抗斯多葛诸神摆在我们面前的挑战时的价值。所以在某种程度上，通过大笑或嘲弄我们面前的挫折作为一种反击的方式。你能谈谈这个想法一会儿吗？是的，如果你能笑过一个侮辱，这个侮辱就不再是你的问题了。
One interesting thing I've discovered is that if somebody says something and you just, you listen, and then you just go on as if they hadn't said it, what they'll do is they'll be puzzled. They'll wonder, well, why didn't he get mad? Why didn't he respond to it? And sometimes they'll say the insult again.
我发现的一个有趣的事情是，如果有人说了什么，而你只是，你听着，然后你继续，就好像他们没说过一样，他们会感到困惑。他们会想，嗯，他为什么没有生气？他为什么不回应？有时他们会再次说出侮辱的话。
And then the response is, yeah sometimes they'll say the insult again. And then the response is, yeah, I heard you the first time. And then you just go on with whatever you were saying. And it's a really profoundly effective way to deal with an insult because they look like a fool. You've just ignored it. They haven't hurt you. So I'm wondering when you think about the COVID-19 pandemic bill. Do you see it as a
然后回答是，是的，有时他们会再次说出侮辱的话。然后回答是，是的，我第一次就听见了。然后你继续说你想说的话。这是一个非常深刻有效的方法来处理侮辱，因为他们看起来像个傻子。你只是忽略了它。他们没有伤害你。所以我想知道当你想到2019冠状病毒病大流行时，比尔。你认为这是
giant stoic test for all of us? Yes, it's a very good stoic test. We talked before about negative visualization in which you imagine losing something that you have and appreciate. COVID-19 is a kind of a brutal substitute for negative visualization. It shows you what it feels like to be deprived of the thing that you appreciate. It could be the company of your relatives. It could be your favorite restaurant. It could be your favorite activity. Hey, stoic gods are going to snatch them away from you so you can figure out what it feels like. The interesting thing about this whole pandemic situation is how people are going to respond to it after it goes away. I'm assuming that it will. It'll be a matter of time before people will be taking everything for granted again.
对我们所有人的巨大斯多葛测试吗？是的，这是一个非常好的斯多葛测试。我们之前讨论过负面可视化，在其中你想象失去你拥有并感激的东西。2019冠状病毒病是负面可视化的一种残酷替代品。它向你展示了被剥夺你所感激的东西是什么感觉。它可能是亲戚的陪伴。它可能是你最喜欢的餐厅。它可能是你最喜欢的活动。嘿，斯多葛诸神会把它们从你身边夺走，这样你就能弄清楚那是什么感觉。关于整个大流行局势，有趣的是人们在它过去后会如何应对。我假设它会过去的。人们重新把一切视为理所当然只是时间问题。
And that's why it's important to be able to practice something like negative visualization because then when you find yourself again taking for granted restaurants, people, and so on, you give yourself a moment to reflect on what it was like during the pandemic and how you felt back then. And that can renew your connection with a variety of relationships. We talked about the movie Groundhog Day at the Starterfile Conversation Bill. Phil Conner tries every self-destructive thing to get out of his quandary but eventually when he realizes that nothing is going to work he starts to slow down.
这就是为什么能够练习像负面可视化这样的事情很重要，因为当你发现自己再次把餐馆、人等等视为理所当然时，你给自己一个时刻去反思大流行期间是什么样的，以及你当时的感觉如何。这可以重新建立你与各种关系的联系。我们在对话开始时讨论了电影《土拨鼠之日》，比尔。菲尔·康纳尝试了各种自毁的事情来摆脱他的困境，但最终当他意识到没有什么管用时，他开始慢下来。
He starts to ask himself how he can appreciate the things that he has, rather than wallow and resentment about the things that he doesn't have. I want to play you a clip from the very end of the movie. When Chekhov saw the long winter, he saw a winter bleak and dark and bereft of hope. Yet, we know that winter is just another step in the cycle of life. But standing here among the people of Punxitani and basking in the warmth of their hearth and hearts, I couldn't imagine a better fate than a long and lustrous winter.
他开始问自己，他如何才能感激自己拥有的东西，而不是沉溺于对没有的东西的怨恨。我想给你放一段电影结尾的片段。当契诃夫看到漫长的冬天时，他看到的是一个荒凉、黑暗、没有希望的冬天。然而，我们知道冬天只是生命循环中的又一步。但站在这里，在庞克苏塔尼的人们中间，沐浴在他们壁炉和内心的温暖中，我无法想象比一个漫长而光辉的冬天更好的命运。
From Punxitani, it's filled connoisse. It's So long. I mean, Phil wakes up the next morning. It actually is the next day. He has escaped his prison. It's almost like he needed to stop trying to escape his prison in order to escape his prison. Absolutely. Here's the stoic bottom line on that. You've got one life to live and it's happening right now. And you have to actively think about what you need to do in order to embrace the one life you have to live. If you spend that life wishing you could be living somebody else's life, that's a waste. So you dig in, you learn how to appreciate what you've already
来自庞克苏塔尼，这是菲尔·康诺斯。再见。我的意思是，菲尔第二天醒来。实际上已经是第二天了。他逃离了监狱。这几乎就像他需要停止试图逃离监狱才能逃离监狱一样。绝对的。关于这一点，斯多葛学派的底线是：你只有一次生命，它现在正在发生。你必须积极思考你需要做什么，以拥抱你仅有的一次生命。如果你把生命花在希望过别人的生活上，那就是一种浪费。所以你深入其中，学会感激你已经
got, you learn how to savor your existence, your environment, your friends, your relatives, your lovers, and you can have that way, the fullest life that's possible to have. William Irvin is a professor of philosophy at Wright State University in Ohio. He's the author of the Stoic Challenge, a philosopher's guide to becoming tougher, calmer and more resilient. Bill, thank you
拥有的，你学会品味你的存在，你的环境，你的朋友，你的亲戚，你的爱人，你可以拥有那种可能拥有的最充实的生活。威廉·欧文是俄亥俄州莱特州立大学的哲学教授。他是《斯多葛式的挑战：成为更坚强、更冷静、更有韧性之人的哲学指南》一书的作者。比尔，谢谢你
for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, it's been a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Mid-Roll Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Our run song Hero Today is Stephen Dubner. Stephen is the host of the podcast Freakonomics. It's a terrific show and you should check it out. But Steven has also been very helpful to me in thinking through what it means to launch
今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。哦，这是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。Mid-Roll Media 是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。我们的片头曲《今天的英雄》由斯蒂芬·都布纳创作。斯蒂芬是播客《魔鬼经济学》的主持人。这是一个非常棒的节目，你应该去看看。但斯蒂芬在思考如何启动
and run an independent production company. He's been generous with his time and incredibly helpful with his advice. I'm so grateful, Steven. Thank you. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and visit us at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
和运营一个独立制作公司意味着什么方面对我也非常有帮助。他毫不吝啬自己的时间，并就如何提供建议提供了令人难以置信的帮助。我非常感激，斯蒂芬。谢谢你。有关《隐藏的大脑》的更多信息，请在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们，并访问 hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子发表评论。